the Joe Rogan experience there's
something to me about music listening to
music - in a plane while you're high mmm
- said it has like extra impact putting
headphones on a plane surrounded by all
these people no one's talking flying
through the sky going 500 miles an hour
30,000 feet above the rocks mm-hmm and
that music kicks in hmm
yeah yeah something about old music -
for me like like lately I've been
getting into a lot of like really old
rock and roll mm-hmm you know just lit
just imagining what it would be like to
like to be around those people you know
see Keith Richards and Mick Jagger in
the 70s and you know to see Little
Richard mmm to see James Brown James
Brown perform a lot mm-hmm yep
there was nothing it's hard for us to
imagine there was nothing like that
before them you know mm-hmm like there's
there's levels of like impact that those
early musicians have that it's hard to
really historically put into place
because there wasn't anybody like them
before that nope no rock-and-roll stars
no rap stars
mm-hmm think of how reason that is yeah
that's super new stand-up comedy is only
about maybe like 70 years old [ __ ] like
that maybe maybe really maybe you could
say a hundred if you want to get crazy
mmm a rappers like 30 30 years old 40
maybe maybe Ford yeah yeah and it keeps
evolving the Bollingen they're like
music in general
my favorite genre is like pop music
right I love anything that could be
considered pop because it changes with
the times but you have these mega stars
you know what I mean who just transcend
like like it's it's it's like soul their
beat their larger-than-life like Michael
Jackson no I'm saying like he's bigger
than just music you know I mean I
and you you've become a legend like as
time goes on but like to be a living
legend like living in those times and to
be around those people that really hear
their music and experience them and [ __ ]
like that I feel like that [ __ ] is crazy
and it's like it's a gift like for the
fans it's a gift to be that person it's
a responsibility as well but just like
to be the one like like Beyonce you know
I mean yeah like that [ __ ] is crazy to
me like to be the one yeah yeah Michael
Jackson was the one when there was no
one before mm-hmm there was no real one
like him I mean there was Elvis and
that's about it
right it was other ones that were big it
was very popular if they're famous but
Michael Jackson transit he transcended
so hard I was listening to WBC n radio
in Boston as a rock and roll station and
there were like I know there's a rock n
roll station but this song is so [ __ ]
good we're gonna play it anyway yeah and
they played Michael Jackson yep and
we're like wow he'd been performance as
a kid so he worked his whole life to get
yeah to be what it will look like 30 or
something like that one yeah probably
when he was on his PGA there was no
there's no roadmap for him nah that [ __ ]
is amazing amazing and he did you know
funk music and he went through disco you
know I mean wow yeah yeah man and I
would have loved to have seen him live
before the controversy right you know
just to just experience him as an artist
yeah without having anything attached to
it what he did or didn't do I don't know
what he did right you know have no idea
right doesn't look good right but I
would have loved to have seen him
without the burden of that filming it
must have been insane and only just to
just to see like he was like a like
we're saying that it needs to be a
different word for work mm-hmm
you know because sometimes does not work
right passion price just it's way better
than work mm-hmm he's a different you
should have a different word for a star
yep because he was like a supernova yeah
he was some rare thing yeah yeah
hmm that might happen once every hundred
years yeah yeah yeah there's legends
like Elton John watts - right and
[ __ ] there's lay all kinds of legends
but then there was Michael Jackson right
he was above all of them yep it was a
mania yeah
kids would dress like him everybody
wanted to wear those thriller jacket
right right yeah there's an art to it I
feel like every musician has a choice
like if they want to go there with it
right yeah I feel like L like the Elton
John's and like even like prints and
[ __ ] like that they stay true to exactly
who they were not that Michael Jackson
didn't stay true to who he was but he
put himself into he put himself out
there for the world he did everything he
did a cartoon mm-hmm he has sneakers he
had he did everything you know out of
the Beatles music yeah he bought yeah
like you know I mean [ __ ] dude on
other people's music yeah but I yeah
hell yeah he was doing the hell of [ __ ]
yeah I just think um there was no road
map for the poor guy right you know yep
when you're living in that fantasy world
that nobody else can understand right
right and there's no one before you and
then everywhere you go people screaming
mm-hmm he never had a break done there's
no breaks there's no you can't do it he
couldn't do anything
no he'll know he'll not not normal
nothing that's crazy that was so the I
wonder if that what that would be like
into like if Michael Jackson came around
today and didn't exist before he would
for sure be a huge star but I wonder if
it would be as crazy because there's so
many more stars now than there were back
then
mm-hmm because of the internet because
that's just more venues and outlets for
musicians one for basically everyone for
comedians for everyone right there's
more outlets yeah so because there's
more outlets there's more famous feet
right I wonder if he would be as correct
it would be as insane because back when
he was that famous it wasn't like anyone
that was parallel not even close
mm-hmm
[Applause]